ils partent de ponos au bord du lac
Titicaca les manifestants bloquent le
pont qui les sépare de la Bolivie ce
sont des Imara en route pour la capitale
Lima il part avec tout ce qu'il faut
pour un long voyage qui pourrait durer
longtemps
[Applaudissements]
ce sont pour la plupart des agriculteurs
Quechua de toute la région qui se
préparent pour 15 heures de route au
moins ceci partent de oumay un peu plus
au nord des volontaires recueillent de
l'argent des couvertures des vêtements
de l'alimentation il se dirigent tous
vers la capitale Lima pour exiger la
démission de la présidente par intérim
Dina bolo Arte et de nouvelles élections
mais au-delà de la destitution de
l'ex-président Pedro Castillo la colère
a des causes plus profondes
contre un état créole qui en 200 ans de
République nous marginalisent c'est une
lutte contre le racisme contre la
pauvreté aussi de cette péruviens sur 10
que la covid a durement touché et contre
l'élite de Lima de longues caravane se
dirige vers la capitale un trajet de
plus de 1300 km pour certains ils sont
prêts à prendre d'assaut le Congrès
Miguel un homme de théâtre qui a vécu
longtemps au Québec n'a jamais vu ça
c'est une situation explosive c'était
l'explosion sociale ça devienne
exploité le gouvernement a décrété
l'état d'urgence mais les manifestants
bravent cette mesure qui leur interdit
de protester des affrontements dans la
région de Puno la semaine dernière on
fait plus de 40 morts tué par balle
quels sont
les gens on ne sait pas qu'est-ce qui va
se passer et les militaires sont pas
préparés pour affronter des
des choses comme ça la grande marche
vers Lima n'a pas de dirigeants connus
ce qui va rendre toute négociation
difficile et la situation encore plus
tendue Jean-Michel auprince et de Canada
Montréal